hey sir what's your question what
religion
I'm full of its land have you ever
looked into eight years old
oh you're a boss and I was in the
streets today and the APS came up to me
and gave me a leaf flip I'd want to know
his evolution the right way
it's not gone now I had a question it's
regarding evolution I do want to know
can we follow it we shouldn't look into
this put doubt in the mind just just
focus on Islam do you do you know [ __ ]
it
recite [ __ ] it if you do have mistaken
[ __ ] white wagons fine I'm from the
local church what religion are you
I'm confused
isn't it sad how that ended a simple
answer could have changed things around
here we live in a society where these
questions are being thrown left rice
into all these misconceptions and
eventually your child is going to come
to you and ask you this question and
some parrots are going to be able to
answer and some are not same way some
Imams are going to be able to answer the
questions and some are not but this is a
risk too high for any of us to take but
we have a solution with our dour
movements we want to tackle these
misconceptions on a daily basis which we
are already doing by reaching millions
of people per month with the click of a
button we do not want your child or my
child to go astray with that simple
question
let's get those questions answered by
becoming a dhow movement member and
supporting us on the link below join the
team join the movement and let's get
those questions answered